[Music]
there's an incredible fallacy that
plagues contemporary train of thought
that insists that in order to feel how
you want to feel you have to get
something you know you won't truly feel
happy confident and motivated unless you
have an awesome car some sweet clothes
and you've landed your dream job it's
the things that we get that determine
how we feel act and live once we get
awesome stuff we'll feel awesome
right it's really easy to fall into this
way of thinking in fact modern
commercial advertising simply wouldn't
exist if it didn't ruthlessly prey on
this way of thinking present within all
of us but the falsity in this train of
thought really becomes apparent when you
compare successful businesspeople with
lottery ticket winners pretend the lower
middle class person who has no idea how
to deal with money suddenly wins a 30
million dollar lottery and becomes a
millionaire worth a fortune
overnight meanwhile in the same city a
successful business person was finally
promoted to the ranks of partner a
position worth 5 million dollars he
worked his way up the corporate ladder
through determination discipline
adaptation innovation and a thousand
lessons learned the hard way so both
people in this moment are worth millions
of dollars however if we end this story
the way it usually ends in real life a
year from now the lottery ticket owner
will be bankrupt he will have had no
idea how to deal with that money
intelligently he will have had some bad
habits and didn't develop the discipline
needed to avoid the temptation of
pouring all that money into those habits
and the businessman will have been smart
with his investment sports the money
back into the company that he worked for
which was rapidly expanding quadrupling
his money over just one year landing him
at a net worth of over 20 million
dollars now the reason why this story
sounds so plausible is because it
happens all the time in real life people
who in large sums of money and haven't
developed the character necessary to
handle it go bankrupt while the people
who actually can handle the money do
well with it so clearly this little
thought experiment reveals that if you
get a lot of stuff you won't be a better
person because of it if the majority of
successful people on the planet are
hard-working energetic passionate people
do you think they inherited those traits
because they became successful or do
those traits have
to do with them becoming successful in
the first place most successful people
would argue the latter prolific writer
Ralph Waldo Emerson has a famous quote
directly related to this way of thinking
and it also happens to be one of the
most hilariously simple quotes of all
time simple but it's still profound and
it goes like this do the thing and you
will have the power that's it he didn't
say that once you have the power you'll
feel like doing the thing he said do the
thing and you will have the power if you
want to be successful do the things that
a successful person would do and you
will have the power you will have
success the 26th President of the United
States Theodore Roosevelt who was a
pretty successful guy had the exact same
philosophy he said that there were all
kinds of things I was afraid of at first
ranging from grizzly bears to mean
horses and gun fighters but by acting as
if I was not afraid I gradually cease to
be afraid Teddy Roosevelt faked it until
he made it and you should too if you
want to eventually have millions of
dollars then be smart with your money
today right now make your own coffee
instead of buying one from Starbucks and
work that extra shift tonight because
that's what somebody who's good with
money would do act like you're good with
money today and you will eventually
become someone who's good with money
aka you'll be rich do the thing and you
will have the power on the same note
don't wait till you're confident enough
to ask that girl out ask her out now
because that's what a confident person
would do if she says no then ask more
girls out even if it terrifies you and
again and again and eventually you'll be
someone who's really confident and
asking girls out act and you will become
do the things you know you should do
even if it feels uncomfortable because
eventually you'll get used to it and
before you know it you will have become
the person you want to be if you liked
this video be sure to hit that like
button and if you like videos like this
in general hit that subscribe button you
may notice that I'm in a different kind
of studio again that's because I'm back
at school and University so I had to
switch backgrounds once again which is
too bad because I really liked that
background in the last video my brother
painted that by the way be sure to
follow us on Instagram Facebook and
Twitter not necessarily in that order at
better ideas TV feels great to get back
in the groove of things and we'll catch
you in the next video